votre rapport propose des solutions
concrètes pour protéger nos enfants mais
pour protéger aussi les actrices de
cette industrie certaines de vos
recommandations rejoignent le travail
d'ores et des a engagés par le
gouvernement avec mon collègue Pape
Ndiaye ministre de l'éducation nationale
nous nous sommes saisis dès notre
arrivée au gouvernement du chantier de
l'éducation à la sexualité il est grand
temps que la loi de 2001 soit appliquée
dans nos écoles je pense aussi aux
travaux pilotés par Jean-Noël Barrault
et Charlotte cobel sur le contrôle
parental sur les smartphones mais nous
pouvons aller plus loin et votre rapport
alimentera grandement les travaux que
nous mènerons prochainement avec mes
collègues de la justice de l'intérieur
de la culture du numérique et de la
protection de l'enfance nous nous
rencontrons vous le savez le 18 octobre
et je sais que nous avancerons ensemble
de manière constructive je vous remercie
[Musique]